hey guys welcome to the wallet podcast
i'm james marshall and thanks for tuning
in to another episode
as always this episode is brought to you
by our awesome partners
pure sports cbd straight face raisers
reagan todd at todd's racing
pomeroy's coffee who have come on with
water lead coffee bean and look out for
water lead tea coming soon
and last but not least the lad merch
which is all but gone now so thanks to
anyone who brought some of that
or any of those products that were just
mentioned there's some great discounts
to be had so if you want to get your
hands on any of those products
head over to waterlab.com and click the
appropriate partner
to go get your discount anywhere i've
got a great layout on for you today so
let's roll the intro
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what
oh guys today i have a man considered a
legend within our family he's been on
the water podcast before in season one
where he produced a
highly downloaded episode and now with
his recent announcements
signing back with his beloved tasman
marco he is coming back on and in a
recent poll that i put up on the
instagram page
89 of you asked for this guy to come
back on
it is of course the one and only thomas
guthrie marshall welcome to thanks mate
um thanks for having me back on the
podcast i know you had a lot of other
guests that were keen to jump on here so
i feel like a real honor to be back on
that podcast
and in the new shed yeah family first
day i mean
lots of guys were keen to come out to
mapua and come into the new studio
but i thought i'd better give you the
test run first what do you reckon
no it's pretty good um for a fairly
amateur podcast you're running a very
professional studio
it's uh it's pretty good fake it till
you make it though
right anyway last time you're on the
podcast you were
about to head off to japan so how was
japan for you
yeah it was um an experience i suppose
um pretty tough one with covert and and
whatnot
not a lot of freedom was you we were
over there
um pretty hard kind of a lifestyle for
my wife beth and uh young
young son chase um they spent a lot of
their time in the apartment
um just with uh with covert it wasn't
wasn't great socially um rugby wise
it was a good experience lucky enough to
have a couple of lads over there and tj
and
banksy um to spend a fair bit of time
with them
and to be honest really enjoyed the
rugby it was a refreshing
change from the uk which was you know
the most
physical game probably in world rugby is
the premiership so
it was refreshing to have kind of
uh japanese rugby players no touch
type defense so i really enjoyed it
you you obviously carved it up over
there too you and tj
massive influence on that side i mean
you guys were shocking the year before
but
turned it around pretty significantly
yeah
i think um tj certainly
definitely one of the most influential
players in the in the top league and
we could easily be none from four if he
wasn't on the field so
no i was it was enjoying playing with
him and um
you know he's he's an inspiring
individual you would know like his work
ethic
his second to none is probably the best
i've ever seen yeah
um and it's hard not to question your
own work ethic when you're around
someone like that and it
inspires you to want to be better as
well yeah so i really really enjoyed my
my time with him
what about banksy oh banksy yeah he's uh
he's the officer yeah he's inspirational
in his own
own mind but um prison break
yeah his work great on netflix is
outstanding
um it's partner he's a hell of a lad
yeah
you know he didn't have it easy over in
in japan either he was by himself
um in an apartment alone and you know he
wasn't getting picked at the
at the start of the season so that was
tough but he fronted up every day at
training always had a smile on his face
and
always had some good perspective and and
always had a good laugh with banksy
usually at his expense
[Laughter]
no it was it was good and he came right
at the end of the year when he got a
chance not what
not came right but when he got a chance
he was he was killing it too so
all that uh pent up frustration that he
had led into one big hit which
would be the whole of his career almost
i'd say it's uh
it's been replayed over and over again
in the team room just
leg drive physicality
so the coaches were loving it yeah oh
that's right everyone was loving it
it's banksy's big moment but he's
he's awesome he was he was ice cold
towards the back end i think he
ended up getting the start in the
quarter final you know he's he's been
there and he's done that so
he just slotted back into this scene
mostly and the 50 meter dash between
banksy and tj that was
talked up for a while there what
happened there i mean we almost got it
off the ground though yeah
no there was a there was a few dynamics
that went into that
banksy was obviously confident at the
start
um but as you know tj's highly
competitive person
he was doing speed training pretty much
every day
genuinely banksy i reckon probably had
seven meters
on him over 50. really there's no way
yeah he would have smoked them yeah he
would have smoked him but
you we got live gps's at training and
his speed times every week we're getting
quicker
and quicker and quicker and towards the
end of the season they were faster than
maxis
so banksy kind of went from you know
keen as to get this race race on board
to
nah sore ankles of all sorts um so no
never really eventually oh i was
wondering what was happening then
because tj kept
pushing it out he said i'll do it at the
end of the year and banksy was keen to
have it early and then
banksy wasn't keen at the end of the
year so dj just went on the boaty
six-week speed program and yeah that was
it that would have been it would have
been an interesting race towards the end
but
um you know maybe there's there's still
time for it i'm in a bit of mitre 10 cup
yeah who knows oh southland wellington
yeah
and you obviously wear a lot of under
armour gear these days so is that um
heavily influenced by tj or what
happened there that's my whole wardrobe
um no tj had a a fairly decent hookup
in japan and you know the the black ears
he
got around the boys and took us into the
store and just said
basically spin whatever you want hello
for free yeah
fill up your bags geez get some clothes
for the misses
yeah all sorts but you know that's just
the type of guy he is he's pretty
pretty generous far right that's good
stuff eh got any
and um you mentioned the japan rugby
like what was the difference between the
japanese rugby compared to the uk
for you as a fullback yep um
well physicality physicality is the the
big one
and the uk is such a different style of
rugby
to anywhere right there's so much
kicking the weather's poor there's a lot
of box kicking
there's a lot of big men and you know
there's not
as much space in japan it's probably a
faster tempo
um you probably get more tired playing
in japan you
run more meters um
and yeah i think that's probably
probably the biggest thing in the
training workload
people always talk about the japanese
training how did you find it with you
at the start it was it was a bit of a
shock but um yeah we had
we were pretty lucky we were at document
we had a um
an aussie trainer oh yeah um he looked
after us pretty good and he made sure
the the workload wasn't company focused
and more more professional so that was
good savior and how's the body feeling
now
yeah it's good um just finished my my
first week of
tessie training so it was a bit of a
bit of an adjustment but no it's nice to
have the weekend off and just just
recover and get ready to go again
so how did the tassie um return come
about i remember me and you always
talked about
both looking to finish our careers here
and
weirdly enough we have but obviously i'm
not playing but
we're both here and you're ready to go
yeah i never would have thought that i'd
be playing and you'd be coaching me at
tasmania
it's pretty loose but um no i guess
towards the end of top league i i knew
that would finish in march and
i knew that the season wouldn't start
next year till january so there was a
bit of time to fill and you know
i think i made contact with you or goody
and
just kind of sniffing around to see if
there was anything there and goodie got
back to me and said that he'd like to
try and make something work so
straight away i was pretty excited about
the prospect of coming home and
getting back into the new zealand rugby
system and just having one last crack at
the marcos
so it is a one one year thing yeah yeah
just a short term
um contract yeah it's a it's a young man
game in new zealand
yeah you know there's so many young kids
coming through and you're the elder stay
yeah i am yeah um this first time in my
career i guess it had to happen at some
stage
but i'm the oldest back at the moment
and by quite a bit
yeah but no it's cool it's refreshing
you know the
young boys are all really keen to learn
and they're really engaged
and um you know it's good to see oh tim
o'malley must be close to you isn't he
yeah bloody bruce he broke my heart i
thought oh yeah
said to him the other day yeah over 30
is off the field but he's like mate i'm
only 26.
i can't believe it and he's probably
what the second oldest yeah i'd say so
yeah
geez you are old and you talked about
the first week
what's the what's the difference being
first week training back with tasman
compared to over in japan
oh just the engagement from the boys
it's
i remember my first meeting kind of
everyone
was talking everyone was engaging
everyone had opinions
everyone was you know standing up and
presenting where
in japan you just don't really get any
of that no they're just
too shy or i don't know maybe they're
daydreaming or
a combination of both um
but yeah certainly the environment that
i was in in japan it was only
two or three people that would talk and
you know the team meetings were kind of
awkward kind of
kind of boring so it's been quite
refreshing coming back here and
listening to everyone's opinion and
seeing the boys that are keen to learn
you know they might not know everything
but they'll still share what
what they think is is right which is
good and you know that's refreshing as
well for obviously being
in the uk environment um we found that
there wasn't a lot of engagement there
either
due to the fear of getting the absolute
piss taken out of here yeah
if you say something dumb yeah you'd
almost find yourself into
the banter's next level you find
yourself in the team meeting just
waiting for someone to say something
stupid so that it can be their nickname
for the year
leah cowan he was always
must be a nightmare for coaches because
they ask questions and no one's going to
say it so in case they get it wrong and
that's them done for the year
but um yeah it's been refreshing and
it's been really good like it's really
professional
at tasman well i'd be surprised if
there's a more professional setup in
terms of the coaches and
the detail and the game plan and how
it's run
um it's pretty it's pretty on board and
it's no surprise as well they've been so
successful
any of the young guys um stand out to
you first week anyone impress you i know
you got a good eye for talent and
potential yeah i mean there's a lot of a
lot of good young kids there right
um they're all obviously young and
they're all
raring to go um i don't really
think it's probably a little bit too
early to sing single out my next all
black you know i don't want to
be let down and i don't want to burden
the young fella so
um yeah we'll see how they go but know
some exciting prospects
oh nice fair enough so the worst thing
about you coming back to
nelson i guess or tasman is the fact
that i have to have conversations with
half a nelson pretending to be you how
many how many combos have you had as me
since you've been back um yeah just the
one in the
in the swimming pool of all places
a big james marshall fan come on over
and say oh
yeah who are you it's like you have
james marsh weren't yeah
at that stage you might as well just say
yep yep yeah there you go
but um yeah not too many not not too
many
people out my poor way no the marshals
out here so it's a good little hiding
spot
yeah for sure anyway um
45 games for tessie approaching the 50
the 50 club think you'll get there um
yeah i'm not too sure i mean that was
part of the reason of coming home
to give myself a chance at least so you
know i'm here
i'm i'm fit at the moment so um
yeah i mean it's definitely a
possibility so yeah we'll we'll see how
we go
pumice bones will hold up hopefully mate
hopefully
i i don't see what why not i just need
to make sure that
train well and if i forget the chance
play well and i think the last time you
were here
we had tri-scrolling songs for each
marco got to choose their own
tri-scoring song
that was not
[Laughter]
got played three times in one game and i
remember um
the tessie guys getting complaints about
their song choice
i'd never scored three tries under the
boardwalk yeah well it must have been a
double
that's a strange straw scoring choice
not wow and obviously the question that
everyone's asked me
or they've probably asked you as well
what's it what's it like being coached
by a brother or what's it like coaching
your brother for me so
how's it been the first week yeah it's
definitely a hot
hot topic everyone asked yet everyone
asked me
yeah um yeah i mean it's cool i suppose
like it doesn't happen happen every day
um
and like i said earlier i didn't think
it would ever happen but yeah it's early
early days
haven't had too many steamy arguments so
far which has been good but
um no i think it would be good it'd be
cool well good answer i think
you might make round one you've said the
right things there
so what's your expectations for the
season for it with tazzy
there's a team yeah i think it'd be
awesome to
win again wouldn't it there's certainly
no reason why not they've got the
players they've got the coaching staff
they've got the setup so um i think
you know that would that would be the
the goal i'd imagine
and what about you personally what's the
goals for
um yeah it's a bit of a weird one really
i don't really have too many goals i
mean it'd be awesome to have that
their 50th game if i get the opportunity
but
um i just want to try and add value to
the team as much as i can in whatever
way i can
but it'll probably be different to how i
have in the past you know obviously
a little bit more older than a lot of
the boys around so it's just probably
getting around those young boys and just
giving as much help as i can and
try and um give them the best chance to
crack on
and what have you have you got anything
planned lined up for after tazzy
after tessie i'm heading back to japan
yeah
um signed a two-year deal at nec
green rockets yeah so um
yeah looking looking forward to that why
why the change of club so how did the
change of club come about
yeah so i was only on a short-term deal
at docomo
i'd signed a i think it was an
eight-month contract all right
um i went there with the hopes and
expectations of
re-signing early enough you know
training well
playing well and getting maybe a
contract extension
it started off started off really well
you know they were impressed with me the
feedback was good
they said that they were pretty keen to
resign me
and i was like yep cool sweet that was
kind of that and then it got towards the
end of the season and
i still hadn't had a contract so i kind
of just
thought background i'm gonna
try my luck somewhere somewhere else
yeah um there's a couple of other
factors you know the
it was quite a tough tough year socially
and
the lifestyle was i didn't overly enjoy
it
i knew tj and marty were leaving so
um you know that was it was a big part
of wanting to
find a different club yeah um and yeah
i kind of kind of left um docomo
with nothing and i was lucky enough to
get a phone call from michael checker
when i was when i was back in new
zealand
yeah he was um asking if i was keen to
come over and
join nec who he's just taken over how
did you know checker
just from what a lab yeah i think he's
he's a big water lad fan
no i've never met michael before
i think he's had conversations with tj
in the past and
i think tj might have mentioned my name
as
a fullback to potentially head to japan
sure
so i think i tj quite a bit for that for
that contract
closet full of under armour and a
contract two-year kick
definitely hey um gotta be grateful for
our pet another son
but yeah no i'm looking forward to a new
change they're based just outside of
tokyo which will be
um yeah a nice a nice change and you
know
by all means they're a pretty uh
underperforming club at the moment but
they're keen to
rebuild and grow grow a team over the
next five years
so yeah they were keen to get someone in
with a little bit of experience and help
help build a culture which would be
exciting so checkers obviously came up
on the podcast a few times brendan
mckibben had a couple of good stories
about him someone else did as well i
can't remember who but
have you had conversations with them on
the phone what's what's that what have
they been like
yeah no i must say i did laugh at
brenda mckibben's stories it was hard
case
um i've had a couple of conversations to
him on the phone and by all means he
seems like
a good bloke you know pretty pretty hard
case but
pretty honest as well yeah which is good
you know he's pretty hard working and he
wants his players to be
be the same so i think he'll drive a
good culture and i think he'll get the
right type of players in as well
and karaoke with checker you reckon oh
no no i don't think i'll jump back into
the karaoke scene last time i did it
um i was with marty banks and we
basically got the mic taken out of our
hands because we we weren't good enough
they take their karaoke pretty seriously
over there were you not in a booth or
were you in
like a small karaoke bar yeah to be fair
that
other people singing were unreal like
they could have been on americans
or anything and then banksy we actually
got pressured into it we didn't want to
do it
and we started singing and they were
pumped up and then as
a couple of verses later they were like
oh no
basically their face is just dropped
um so no i think that's probably scarred
me from karaoke
fair enough you used to love it under
the boardwalk big big
from memory that was your other go to a
yeah just
just an aegis classic that one
oh so with nec how long did you gig with
nec
two years any plans after that see how
it goes
yeah we'll just see how see how we go i
wanna
obviously try and play rugby for as long
as i can and as long as the body's
feeling good
um at the moment it's been feeling
really good i really enjoyed my first
season
in japan um but you know two years
there's a lot of water under the bridge
so
we'll see how we're going after that
what's your gut say how long do you
reckon you've got left
i thought you'd be done by now to be
honest but you're still going
i was pretty much done at 25
second wind to fear the five years i had
at gloucester was just five years of
rehab to get me into really good shape
for tessie yeah building up since i've
um so but genuinely i didn't play a lot
of rugby in those five years so it's
probably extended my career and
coverts been a savior you know i was
feeling pretty sore
before covert and then this last year's
been unreal because i've only played a
few games so
no i don't know we'll see how we go 35
would be nice wouldn't it you might go
for the mark bright 42 record oh
friday 42 no the man's afraid i don't
know how anyone plays that age
that's crazy yeah [ __ ] he was i remember
him at tasman he was old as
and to think it's 12 years later he's
still going
yeah and he was sore as well yeah he
wasn't he was like a once a week trainer
captain's run type of a player yeah it's
unbelievable to
keep yourself going for that long yeah
they let him go from tasmania because he
was too old and
he's still playing 12 years later i
think i was 19
and he was like one of the old guys
remember that kk had the conversation
and said mate
you're too old we can't we can't kick
you and then that following season he
was playing for england
yeah that's right and then 11 years
later he's still going
he must have just been filthy at kk's
words i reckon and just
prove a point great motivation yeah
there'd be a few people around the
country that would have had good
motivation from kkk
what was your best one i was lucky to be
feeling i didn't get too much
um on the bed sort of kind of you did
well
yeah i don't know the old mutton head
but
i probably wasn't listening in the
meeting
yeah fair enough and you're back in
nelson and looking to
join this waterlab brewery we're looking
to brew a beer together how cool is that
yeah no it's exciting isn't it um what a
lad what a beer
um early days isn't it yeah we're
probably in the fun stage of the
operation
yeah the sampling sampling a good
classic right now this is a
water led hazy which hopefully will be
on the shelves within
i don't know how long the process takes
but maybe a couple of months it'd be
good to have it going by the end of
yeah do maybe a woodland lager for the
end of year do and then
yeah what allowed hazies for the summer
yeah no i'm sure there'll be um
there'll be a big engagement of
waterland fans you know
all the boys that come on seems to not
mind a
[Music]
few few stories for sure so i think
it'll be cool
and brad webber who does love it bro he
had you as the best diesel
he's ever played with that that's a huge
thing for the cv
what did you do to impress her it's a
hell of a shout out yeah it is a good
one for the cv
when you're younger but you know as you
get older it's
probably not overly appealing to be
labeled the best diesel
a fair bit of pressure on um
you know but um i'm not sure what i did
to
oh i've got an inkling could have been a
could have been a fantastic game of uh
can a hole that we
we played and hamilton one time and
yeah it's just one of those days where
you know you put a beer back and
you just crack open another one and yeah
you were just on you're just on some
days they go down real well and they
were going down well that day
but um no how do they go down now
obviously a bit older you've got a kid
now so oh don't get me wrong i still
love a bear but
you know there's time and place it's
it's not the same
waking up and having to look after a kid
as opposed to
beaching all day on netflix and
deliveroo so yeah
yeah you gotta you gotta choose your
time wisely and um yeah
every now and again i like to push the
boat out yeah end of year do
boys expect a big performance from you
jeepers
um yeah i've been listening to the the
podcast obviously there's a few tessie
boys that
seem to go pretty keen yeah the indian
deuce i think next is after you actually
yeah oh it's good to see the tradition
still going strong
yeah it'll be good did you start that
tradition no no it's just
you know tizzy boys were never any good
at rugby but
we went bloody good at the indiana dude
and now that they're getting better at
rugby they're still
still good on the do which is good
keeping it strong yeah
yeah good well anyway as always we've
gone to our instagram for some questions
and
we almost had a live one from big paddy
mcallister who
was going to start till 3am to ask you
one but
looks like he's falling asleep but we
have got plenty of questions
and he has sent a lot in okay first
question this one is from patty he got
this one and before he fell asleep
top three lads to go on the piss within
your travels
um top three lads to get on the
pissworth um
yeah there's been a fair few good dudes
over in the uk
um i'd say
started off with thrushy mm-hmm it'd be
one of my favorites
yeah yeah he came over from
new zealand pretty serious about his
footy not really
have let us hear down too much and ended
up absolutely losing the plot in
gloucester so
we had good times and um good scottish
lad matt scott
he was always one of my favorites um
as you know you've probably met a few
scotsmen they're they're not afraid of a
few brews and i remember scotty on your
stag do he was he was
right on yeah yeah well and truly lost
the gherkin i don't know if he's ever
recovered from that to be fair
fair enough and then i'm gonna have to
go
four all go like they come as a package
paddy mcallister and and olly thorley um
a couple of good lads that i met in in
gloucester yeah we had
had a lot of good times with them um
yeah good crew sounds like a good crew
okay the next one who would win in a
fight ollie thorley or a puppy
um definitely a puppy
ollie he's probably well he's ex to be
fair he's pretty aggressive on the rugby
field
he's a big boy yeah he's a big boy and
he's aggressive
and he's he's he's pretty tough on the
field but off
off the field he's he's a bit like a
kitten so be a kitten versus a puppy
which would
hey to be fair is a good fight
pay-per-view pay-per-view
get it on want a game of fingers guess
who asks us
oh sweetie swings loves that swings
loves the game fingers no to be fair
it's one of my favorite
drinking games yeah don't often lose and
every now and again it gets me though
yeah swains
did swings ever get you um oh
no i wouldn't have thought so surely not
okay next one what position do you want
to be playing this season
whatever i'll be pretty happy to slot in
the 15 jersey or
wherever it was available fifth day
sounds good thanks coach
21 it is can you ask him what he thinks
of pornecki premier
george jacobs george jacobs
name sounds very familiar um yeah good
good player works hard decent physique
on him
yeah he is a lad okay next one any
chance of a round of captain insano oh
someone wants to go one-on-one with you
who is it what's this size
i'm not sure i've lost a fair bit of uh
wrestling confidence yesterday we
had jiu-jitsu that's part of the tasman
marco
training and i got tapped out pretty
much every single time
um but i guess captain asano is fairly
niche and
i've got a fair bit of experience behind
it so i'll probably go right you can't
beat experience in captain and xena
no exactly i know what i'm doing in that
situation how come in the jiu-jitsu you
didn't get it going
oh you should have got one of the boys
right
in one yeah to be fair i probably could
have you're not allowed on your feet
though
pretty hard to kneecap valentina yeah do
it do a knee captain i say no yeah
true okay this one why don't you stay in
new zealand and try and play for the all
blacks
um yeah i mean i was in new zealand for
five years and i was
trying my best to make the all blacks
um but no when i was 25 i was sore
very sore had real bad patella tendon
and i was probably
battling for a couple of years and to be
honest i left new zealand and
thought i probably only had a couple
years left in me um lucky enough i got
surgery and
they had good medical staff over in the
uk that looked after me and got me back
to
full health and then yeah that's kind of
how
it's now you're here and and now i'm
back i'm ready for the all blacks
no and yeah and now now i'm back um
yeah i'm looking forward to playing a
little bit of bit of rugby hopefully
with
without a sore knee would you play for
the all blacks if you had a huge
bunnings would i play for the all blacks
if they had a big bunnings
oh mate would you
um i don't know like it's not something
i've thought about at all
[Music]
plum lessons
okay this one where'd you get your
fitness from
where'd i get my fitness from um just
from running
ah reckless box goody one mil
i was like that's a loose weird question
fair play
chop it with easy
oh fair play andrew goodman that's a
strong start i knew this question would
be coming
what's it like being the best rugby
player in your family oh classic
i hate those questions there
to get it all the time yeah all the time
me too
being the best looking in your family
yeah okay do you think your older
brother should come out of retirement
and boost nelson club next year
oh 100 i don't know if i'm allowed to
say that
this at the moment but he is planning a
return to play
my round eight tasman marcos stay
tuned we will see
i cannot even walk mate i'd love to put
on the nelson ruby football club top one
more time but
mate i would be doing you no favors
okay next one who's your favorite
all-time marco
yeah um
i'm gonna go for
shane christie oh fair enough absolute
workhorse
you know and and a hell of a captain
he's the guy
that you want to play for so you know i
guess it's a
natural transition into a coach because
you know he's
he's pretty he's pretty intense but
he wants to get the best out of
absolutely everyone and he's he's got
passion
you just see it in his eyes so he's he's
always been pretty inspirational
it's a good option to try and push for
that start
chances goody will be filthy
hardest player to tackle
there's been a few
thus in his prime was pretty lethal oh
yeah he got you a couple of good times
there
yeah nice pretty hard um
what's up in a holiday made of concrete
yeah got me a couple of times dislocated
shoulders um
i think the answer might be sitting
right in front of you
you're searching for answers that's a
terrible picture
i got you mate i got you around the boot
ladies
you actually didn't i broke it but i ran
into touch no
i did i did get the
no i definitely broke the tackle but i
went straight into touch and you know
what was such a [ __ ] play but i was
actually quietly stoked
yeah turn over i would have got the
turnover then so
uh not a bad result yeah um but now
the the big boys that that can run quite
fast always quite tough
have you tackled jim the plus yet no
heaven
very low center of granite gravity yeah
stocky
rock fijians yeah made a concrete eh
concrete cover
okay next one best player that you've
played with oh
you've played with a lot of teams a lot
of players all around the world
yeah a lot of a lot of good players
there it's tough flight
it's all very subjective isn't it like
yeah there's
this locks best team might be in front
of you again
now obviously when you're at the
crusaders you were playing with a pretty
stacked side cardinal mccoy sonny bell
all those guys
it's carter's card is unreal like he's
probably all around
like the best player that i've played
with he's
he's unbelievable um i think
gloucester was pretty lucky to play with
danny cipriani as well
he's probably the best ball player
that i've played with um
but yeah i think over overall dc the
goat
what makes cipriani such a good ball
player don't know i just think he's
really gifted yeah like he'll hit the
right pass
every time and you know he knows
he's just understands the game like he's
just such a wizard in how he wants the
game to be played
um if he got everyone thinking like he
thinks like you wouldn't be able to stop
them but
unfortunately a lot of players known and
that's where
that's where the downfall down four is
and a lot of frustration seeps in but
um no he's a hell of a gifted bull
player yeah and tj must be floating
around on that list somewhere right
after you've played with him and he's
hooked up with the contract
unlimited clothing yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
tj's unreal isn't he like he's he's
influential
he's definitely probably the
the most the biggest competitor that
i've played with you know he fights for
absolutely everything and
he's probably not the best all-round
player but
man he makes up for it with his
competitive edge and when he walks out
on the field
he often more times or not he's comes
off at the best player
crazy i love that okay weirdest teammate
you've had
geez it'd be a few of these too
weirdest teammates isn't it
i don't know if we work environments
like that but there's so
many weirdos do you reckon
i don't know there's always a couple of
like really cooked roosters
um weirdest teammate ben coman must be
in and around
oh yeah he's a real crook rooster
um to be fair
you're probably not gonna know who he is
but i reckon he's probably the weirdest
teammate i've played with and
val rapala rush rushkin oh yeah
he's a prophet at gloucester um where's
he from
who knows i think he's a compulsive liar
so
one minute he's he says he's from
georgia but he could be from anywhere
he's one of those guys that tells so
many stories you're just not
sure what what's right what's wrong
i literally think he's he's got a
condition where he just has to lie
um which is interesting yeah
get him on the phone get him on the
podcast asking some questions
see where he takes it huh yeah
oh good stuff okay this question is from
brad webber
um would love to hear your best yarn
about the big man
whopper oh the big man
[ __ ] deezy um i was lucky enough to live
with him
in the tron for two years um
plenty of stories unfortunately a couple
of them
have got to go to the grave but um
one yarn that sticks out for me
would be the absolute stitch up so
we used to live next door to the
mangrove
um yeah they had a uh
a dog a mob dog on their letterbox type
thing and they'd come out
and their patches and stuff like that
absolutely harmless i think you know
that there was a
family house so there wasn't much going
on there
but um what used to give me a ride to
training every now and again
and the friend friendly boat he is a big
lad you know
from a small town always wants to say
good day to everyone so he'd always wind
down the window and wave and say g'day
mate
to the mongrel mob leader which you know
i'd always be like [ __ ] hell wolf i
don't do that
but it was nothing really yeah but then
one day we got back from
uh training we had a note saying
tell your fat [ __ ] mate tonight never
[ __ ] wave
to me ever again otherwise that'll be it
and so poor old beth it was me beth and
wappa that lived in the house
poor old beth received the note from the
mongrel mob
and she was ringing me pretty much in
tears looking up
replacement rentals for real
saying we had to move out of there i
told the big man he's like oh
no they seemed alright when i waved to
them and like all this stuff we have
[ __ ]
panic stations for for the whole day
and um lo and behold it was a bloody
prank of a lifetime from the mackenzie
brothers
goddamn that's a waddlehead prank that's
an absolute classic it would if it
hadn't been filmed it would have been
gold but
um i can't remember what we did to big
jim but
that was that was a payback prank and
they absolutely trumped us
oh that's good stuff what a yarn okay
last question toei
oh what's the best piece of advice
you've ever received
i remember when i was probably first
year of the
crusaders there's a good lad that
was uh cory flynn oh
older bloke been around a while
absolutely lad
he must have been you know on his last
couple of years and he just said
to me having a couple of beers after the
game he just said
make sure you enjoy the rod because you
know it goes so fast and it really does
like i don't feel like
i'm 31 now and i can't believe it's it's
been 11 years since i
i first started playing rugby
professionally um
but i've definitely made sure i've
enjoyed it um
so you know i think that's important to
get that balance right you know train
hard
do your work and then um make sure you
you enjoy yourself afterwards and
yeah i think that's a big part of the
game what do you reckon the risk is of
guys taking the game too seriously
and not enjoying that ride well they're
going to get well
i i think you'd get to the end of your
career and you'd just be like man i just
full of regrets i've been to so many
places i didn't see it because i was
too bogged up on recovering and making
sure that i ate the right thing and
didn't experience what all the good
things that rugby can give you as well
i think you've got to get the balance
really right because you know there's a
time and place for it you know you don't
want to go to south africa and put on
five
kgs an average 2.2 milkshakes
a day but at the same time you don't
want to lock yourself in the room
because
you're recovering on your your game
ready or whatever you're doing you
you need to get the balance right and
you need to enjoy it because you know
you never know when your last game
ruby's going to be yeah
jeez that's powerful stuff from you okay
you've listened to a lot of
what a lad podcast and you've taken a
little bit of everyone's advice and just
crammed it in there it's so good
i love it what a way to finish the
podcast but
mate really appreciate you coming on the
podcast really looking forward to having
you back
playing for your beloved tasman marco
looking forward to coaching you
stoked to have you back in mapua and
ready to put on that tesla marco jersey
and then
obviously your time over in japan and
nec looking forward to seeing how that
all goes for you and beth and chase as
well so
appreciate you coming on the podcast
mate cheers jimmy nice to be back on
here
um looking forward to the season with
you and
maybe uh getting some further progress
with this delicious waterload beer
yeah there's any listeners out there
that have any requests or
any types of flavor that they like fire
it through to the
the water lad webpage website i don't
know what you're running these days
you've got that many bloody things
facebook website sheds
studios you'll have an assistant soon
but now follow that feedback across and
then i'm sure there's big things coming
in the pipeline maybe
a few exclusive little ad events
sponsored by waterloo diesel
what allowed stag news oh we're going
places
big things are happening in the studio
but
if you do have any ideas around this bed
yeah do send them in this is like even
if you're a brewer or someone who wants
to make a beer and
be part of the journey get in touch and
you can join this
awesome beer which is going to take over
the world because this one here man this
was just a sample but wow
this is going down a tree oh it is nice
very nice
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
what